proche du virus ebola le virus a marre
bourgue et récemment réapparu en afrique
causant la mort d'un homme avec un taux
de létalité avoisinant les 50 % cette
maladie est déjà responsable de
plusieurs centaines de morts alors quels
sont les symptômes de cette maladie
comment le virus se transmet t-il et
faut-il craindre une flambée épidémique
aux portes de l'europe les réponses dans
ce nouvel épisode de factures
[Musique]
marc burg ce nom est à l'origine celui
d'une ville située au centre de
l'allemagne c'est ici qu'un virus
inconnu à paris en 1967 des singes verts
importés d'ouganda à l'institut de
virologie de marc bourgue contaminent
des chercheurs la même année deux autres
foyers sont déclarés un second en
allemagne et un autre en serbie au total
sept personnes décèdent des suites de la
maladie en europe marbour c'est un virus
qui a un aspect de virus très très long
1 d'où le nom de la famille à laquelle
appartient la famille des filous série
des films et cette famille regroupe
plusieurs virus notamment les virus
ebola des sondés les virus qui les
provoquent des défiait vrai qu'ils sont
fuis dit pas forcément toujours
d'hémorragie mais qui sont suivis de
perte de volume 1 de l'équipe dans un
organisme qui avoue dit souvent à la
mort du patient angola ouganda afrique
du sud kenya mais aussi république
démocratique du congo le virus marburg
frappe à plusieurs reprises l'afrique de
l'est toutefois un cas d'infection au
virus marc burg a récemment été déclaré
en guinée le 9 août 2021 il s'agit du
premier cas de la maladie déclarée en
afrique de l'ouest c'est une nouvelle
région de circulation du virus mais on
pouvait s'y attendre ce n'est pas très
étonnant evola je voulais pour la
première fois donc il ya six ans dans
cette région la mort peu après ce n'est
pas très étonnant le parallèle avec
ebola et pertinent sur trois points les
symptômes le mode de transmission ainsi
que la localisation géographique
premiers éléments les symptômes induits
par ces deux maladies sont semblables
provoquant des fièvre des vomissements
ainsi que des diarrhées second élément
qu'il s'agisse de la première
contamination de la propagation de la
maladie des similitudes sont à noter
comme plusieurs autres maladies sévères
ce cousin d'ebola parvient jusqu'à
l'homme par le biais d'un animal servant
de réservoir à la maladie ici ce sont
les chauves-souris qui sont met en cause
le réservoir animal très simplement pour
les virus et voilà mais très sûrement
pour les virus marburg sont des
chauves-souris différentes types de
souris le virus pénètre c'est l'homme
lors d'un contact direct ou indirect
avec ses chaussons dans de nombreux cas
il ya eu un espace intermédiaire qui est
infecté par ce virus itier et ramené
dans les villages campings de bronze et
ses animaux qui sont apportées pour être
pour être mangés mettre en contact le
virus qui l'emmenait de la photo cette
zone hausse est d'autant plus
contagieuse dommage d'après
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
celle ci se propage par le biais du sang
des sécrétions des organes ou des
liquides biologiques de personnes en
fait
ou avec des surfaces et des matériaux
contaminés par ces liquides enfin ce
premier cas du virus marburg détecter
cette année intervient en guinée dans la
préfecture de guéckédou au sud du pays
c'est exactement dans cette même région
forestière que la toute première
épidémie d'ebola ainsi que la toute
dernière se sont déclarés effectivement
c'était le berceau de la grande épidémie
d'ebola qui aussi de la première
épidémie et voilà en afrique de vote
probablement parce que il y a là un
écosystème à la fois où les jours sourit
et pour l'homme qui fait que c'est un
terreau propice à la circulation virale
chez les souris et le passage de nautica
l'homme en clans ces phénomènes et punis
cette maladie hautement virulente a
toutefois un taux de létalité soit le
risque d'entraîner la mort très variable
en effet il faut prendre en contre la
charge virale qui évoluent en fonction
de la mutation du virus ainsi que la
gestion des cas le virus margot et très
mortels sont certes un nombre important
de morts parmi les tiens malades
diagnostiqués par l'entrée 25-30 % juste
même 80% on va retenir un peu mortalité
à 50% ça n'a rien à voir avec le virus
qui ne prennent actuellement qui le sert
stock deux responsables de maladies
communes 19,6 pour l'heure aucun vaccin
ou traitement on a été mise au point une
prise en charge précoce accompagné du
traitement des symptômes spécifiques
améliore nettement les taux de survie
bien que les experts s'accordent à dire
qu'il est probable que de nouveaux cas
émerge le risque de voir apparaître la
maladie en france est toutefois faible
on a vraiment un virus qui est
concentrée en afrique de l'ouest on l'a
bien vu avec evola le risque de
transmission en europe des très faibles
quasi inexistant
[Musique]